uncle Joey here then the Colorado down
the block for my favorite spots and
green chile
smoking a J right under a tree ain't
bother nobody
the DEA no dude picked on me I'm uncle
Joey [ __ ] I'm saying I've been smoking
it's just before the DEA was [ __ ] even
around we got some [ __ ] banana
Oh G from perennial
I just had a bowl of tremendous green
chili I'm gonna go up to my room after I
smoked this bone and take a little nap
wake up maybe do a little workout and
then we got a sold our [ __ ] show at
comedy what do you think about that
[ __ ] right here that's like a doctor
you think I give a [ __ ]
let me taste some I've been smoking dope
like this since I was 13 out of the
street what I got them willing to throw
you in [ __ ] jail what I gonna do who
gives a [ __ ] at this point if you give a
[ __ ] about legalization and all that
[ __ ] you're out of your [ __ ] mind I'm
gonna keep smoking till they [ __ ]
throw me under the [ __ ] jail you
understand me
I don't care about Gentile forget my
mother's [ __ ] and that's the
way I felt for the last 30 [ __ ] years
and nothing's gonna change you think I'm
worried about some [ __ ] medical
marijuana license or something get the
[ __ ] out of here
uncle Joey's Jimmy runs beep so deep put
that ass to sleep you don't I'm DEA call
you [ __ ] Gentiles are running scared
oh my god
it's time to go who gives a [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] do you think I give a [ __ ]
do you think the [ __ ] heads I don't
really give a [ __ ] this for Gentiles you
people with licenses to believe all this
[ __ ] me I'm gonna keep smoking till they
deport me back to [ __ ] Q by you like
that you know why cuz that's how I roll
you know what I know you [ __ ]
know my father
my name is Diaz but my maiden name is
Valdes my mother's maiden name and there
was a Valdez and a Diaz I'm the [ __ ]
Santa Maria were Columbus how the [ __ ]
you gonna tell me what to do concept it
mm-hmm stoned to the gills I love this
[ __ ] tomorrow night that she but you
people come to the show they're bringing
the mints nibbling and [ __ ]
everything we got everything at the club
this week I can't tell you how happy I
am I can't tell you I can't begin to
[ __ ] tell you how happy I'll go Joey
is right now
everybody's trying to put me down with
the DEA this one do I give a [ __ ]
this one ask any of my buddies I've
never given a [ __ ] I've never given a
[ __ ] you want to throw me in jail for we
go ahead we're too strong right now
we're stronger than us steel look at me
from the [ __ ] tree like a doctor like
I owned this [ __ ] why because I
love you [ __ ] how am I gonna
[ __ ] time look at this I got atom
into you in my [ __ ] way
how am I gonna taint it be free to be a
savage if I'm hiding in some [ __ ]
alley I'm saying
are you doing concert you and that all
[ __ ] goat in the cop doesn't suck my
dick I think I never saw somebody still
gonna join the street before would you
just crawl under a rock [ __ ] I got
a [ __ ] Hindu that's more American
than these [ __ ] anyway that's it that's
that uncle Joey loves you and that's all
that matters were in Denver here two
shows tomorrow night two shows Friday
night and the party keeps going so if I
was you I'd show up look at these
notices looking looking number one it's
number two
where's Isis when you need them that's a
[ __ ] that's a two-shot that's a one
bullet [ __ ] deal right there with
[ __ ] backpacks on like they're
[ __ ] discovering sir okay what the
[ __ ] is wrong with these Gentiles but
anyway what done is when this joint gets
really good was down here
you know I love you [ __ ] we'll be
doing this every [ __ ] day when I'm in
Denver to prove a point sometimes two
joints I'll see you tonight [ __ ]
stay black uncle Joey loves you